io non guardavo mai la tv ho vissuto
molti anni all'estero e quindi non
potevo guardare la tv italiana
però tutte le volte che tornavo in
italia facevo un gesto semplicissimo
accendevo la televisione accendevo la
televisione è quello che vedevo mi
stupiva primo punto che vi chiedo di
tenere a mente
vedevo cose che non vediamo negli altri
paesi europei
almeno non in questa quantità guardavo e
mi domandavo e come ho sempre fatto fin
da bambina di fronte a delle cose che
non funzionano avevo voglia di reagire
quindi telefonavo gli amici e gli amici
che vivono in italia perché pensavo di
aver colto qualcosa che non funzionava
ma solo in quel momento marco un amico
marco ma sono davanti alla televisione
sono le sei del pomeriggio ci sono
bambini e bambine davanti c'è una
ragazza sotto il tavolo come se fosse le
gambe del tavolo è la risposta era ma
lorella scusa questa è la televisione a
tornavo all'estero dopo qualche mese
tornavo accendevo la tv mamma mamma
scusa accendi la televisione o sto
vedendo una cosa pazzesca credo di aver
beccato un'immagine che non può andare
in onda sono le sei del pomeriggio
c'è una ragazza appesa come un
prosciutto come in un campo di
concentramento col sedere scoperto quasi
nuda e tutti ridono telefoniamo la
trasmissione e mia madre rispondeva ma è
la tv la stessa risposta che mi aveva
dato marco che aveva un'altra età
un'altra un'altra cultura un altro
ambiente un altro mondo quindi mi
accorgevo che mentre ero stata via la
televisione era diventata quella cosa
che vedevo quando tornavo e pensavo ma
in quante famiglie arriva quante persone
sta influenzando quante ragazze e
ragazzi quanti bambini e quanti bambine
ma non vedevo una reazione e mi chiedevo
come mai
quindi avuto voglia di fare qualcosa non
era
non era esattamente il mio mestiere ma
volevo arrivare ai ragazzi e alle
ragazze italiane ho detto come ci arrivo
un libro si ma un libro poi i ragazzi e
le ragazze non lo leggono un video un
video ok proviamo a fare un video quindi
ho chiesto a degli amici che lavoravano
in questo campo detto facciamo un video
da mettere online quindi breve che
arrivi ai ragazzi e ragazze obiettivo
innalzare il livello di consapevolezza
dire non è così da tutte le altre parti
la tv può anche fare bene non per forza
fare male può rappresentarci bene non
per forza rappresentarci male ci sono
degli esempi ci siamo messi insieme ad
altri due amici marco malfi cesare cantù
abbiamo visto in poche settimane 400 ore
di intrattenimento televisivo ci siamo
focalizzati sull'intrattenimento e da
quello abbiamo ricavato venti minuti di
un video che abbiamo deciso poi di
mettere online
oggi non possiamo vederne tutti i venti
minuti ne vediamo tre minuti uno
spezzone ricordo quando mar come diceva
che la tv ha un potere incredibile pur
parlando del reale e rappresentando il
reale riesce a dissimulare la tv oggi
ruba deturpa min e il paesaggio della
coscienza di tutti ci toglie le radici e
le fondamenta molti ricondotti a
maschere dalla chirurgia estetica corpi
gonfiata a dismisura come fenomeni da
baraccone di un circo perenne che ci
rimandano un'idea di donna contraffatta
il reale allora sono sicura che la tv la
puoi guardare la puoi sopportare ma solo
pensando che un grande circo
chi siamo cosa vogliamo
come mai tutte le donne d'italia non
scendono in piazza protestando per come
veniamo rappresentate
dei 45 muscoli facciali a parte quelli
necessari per masticare baciare odorare
soffiare tutti gli altri servono per
esprimere emozioni più articolato e
complesso sarà il carattere intendendo
per carattere la nostra essenza più
profonda più individuale sarà
l'espressione del volto
cosa stanno nascondendo questi volti
perché le donne non possono più apparire
con la loro vera faccia in tv perché non
c'è più nessuna donna adulta che possa
mostrare il suo volto perché questa
umiliazione
dobbiamo avere vergogna di mostrare la
nostra faccia dover nascondere le nostre
rughe il passaggio del tempo che lascia
le sue tracce sul nostro volto e dunque
una vergogna ennesimo sopruso a cui
nessun uomo viene obbligato
diceva anna magnani al truccatore che
prima del ciak stava per coprirle le
rughe del volto lasciamele tutte non me
ne togliere nemmeno una ci ho messo una
vita a farmele
perché non reagiamo perché non ci
presentiamo nella nostra verità perché
accettiamo questa umiliazione continua
perché non ci occupiamo dei nostri
diritti
di che cosa abbiamo paura
abbiamo messo questo video online
quattro anni fa non abbiamo investito un
euro in campagne stampa non abbiamo un
agente che ci rappresenta dal giorno
dopo è stata un'esplosione
abbiamo ricevuto avevamo un blog il
corpo delle donne migliaia migliaia
migliaia di persone che ci scrivevano il
tema conduttore è la cosa più comune che
ci scrivevano era pensavo la stessa cosa
ma non avevo le parole per dirlo
pensavo la stessa cosa ma non aveva le
parole per dirlo perché questa
attenzione che abbiamo da quattro anni
sulla televisione molti ci dicono ma
zanardo adesso internet perché questa
attenzione per la televisione
allora andiamo a vedere un pochino i
dati se io chiedessi per esempio a
questa platea
se volete rispondermi chi di voi non ha
la tv ok io vi vedo da qua non so dirvi
in percentuale ma un 23 per cento della
platea
chi ne ha una ok grazie chi ne ha 2
ok chi ne ha 3 ok chi ne ha 4 ok allora
quando andiamo in giro per l'italia da
qui che cosa vi posso dire chi non ne ha
è un 23 per cento chi ne ha una e chi ne
ha due era la maggioranza quando andiamo
in giro per l'italia questo è il dato
più ricorrente cosa ci dicono i dati
l'utenza complessiva al 98 e poco più
per cento delle persone alla tv che cosa
vuol dire la tv continua a essere un
mezzo visto dagli italiani e dalle
italiane tutti o quasi tutti abbiamo una
due al sud quando facciamo questa
domanda da roma in giù spesso tre o
quattro il sud è alto consumante si dice
in gergo di tv generalista perché ci
tengo a dire questo vuol dire stiamo
capendo qui oggi insieme che la tv
continua a essere il maggiore mezzo di
informazione per gli italiani e italiane
lo dico perché l'altra sorpresa che
abbiamo avuto da quando uscito il
documentario che c'erano persone poche
poche ma le persone che hanno una grande
influenza che sono le persone che
dirigono i giornali gli intellettuali
professori universitari che alzavano la
mano ai nostri dibattiti dicevano
zanardo però io la tv basta non
guardarla non è così semplice basta non
guardarla per noi che scegliamo oggi di
essere qui a sentire una cosa bella ma
gli italiani alle italiane guardano
invece la tv perché perché siamo scarsi
lettori di quotidiani
ecco perché è importante correlare i
dati è perché c'è anche un altro dato se
noi confrontiamo i dati di quanta gente
guarda la tv in italia è lo stesso
numero di persone che ritroviamo in
inghilterra l'inghilterra abbiamo lo
stesso numero di utilizzatori di tv ma
gli inglesi poi leggono tanti quotidiani
voi potete dirmi zanardo rende il sun
certo ma lo leggono vanno a teatro a
vedere anche spettacoli miseri ma ci
vanno leggono libri brutti ma li leggono
quindi le informazioni agli inglesi
vengono da diversi canali agli italiani
e le italiane principalmente vengono
dalla televisione incrociamo questo con
un altro dato dati ocse recentissimi
abbiamo il tasso di abbandono scolastico
tra i più alti d'europa in particolare
in alcune zone della campania c'è il
tasso di abbandono scolastico più alto d
europa guardate questo è il dato più
allarmante che abbiamo sentito negli
ultimi anni è perché è importante quando
cresciamo ci sono tre potenti agenti di
socializzazione
poi se ne aggiunge un quarto da adulti
che il mondo del lavoro e della famiglia
la scuola e la tv la famiglia stamattina
prima di venire qui mi ha chiamato una
radio mi ha detto zanardo cosa pensa
delle bambine che si prostituiscono è
colpa delle madri e la mia risposta è i
cittadini di un paese democratico non
sono l'effetto di un caso ma sono il
risultato di un processo educativo
quindi non voglio di responsabilizzare
le famiglie
ricordando che però ci sono anche i
padri ma vorrei puntare il dito su una
cosa dobbiamo assolutamente potenziare
gli altri due agenti di socializzazione
che sono la scuola che viene
perennemente depauperate negli ultimi
anni e tornare ad avere un servizio
pubblico degno di questo nome perché
attraverso la tv possiamo fare dei
cambiamenti epocali
dico solo velocemente che negli anni
sessanta c'era una trasmissione lo dico
per i più giovani e le più giovani che
si chiamava non è mai troppo tardi se lo
dite adesso qualche intellettuale store
kander storce il naso dice ma vogliamo
rivolgerci al passato no ma in quegli
anni venivano persino dal giappone
imparare come si faceva buona
televisione in italia attraverso quella
trasmissione
un milione e mezzo di italiani prese la
licenza elementare tornare a fare buona
tv impossessarsi almeno di un canale
televisivo vuol dire cambiare le sorti
del paese
c'è anche un tasso altissimo di
analfabetismo funzionale vuol dire che
non siamo più i letterati nel senso
sappiamo leggere scrivere ma a stento
capiamo dei ragionamenti che siano un po
anche solo un pochino complicati
c'è un dato che non tutti conoscono ma è
importante siamo migliorati un po ma nel
global gender gap report che viene
stilato dal world economic forum
l'italia settantesimo posto è un indice
che misura la differenza che c'è tra i
sessi sono stata badate che tutti i
paesi europei sono tra i primi 20
è un dato di cui in italia si parla poco
in aprile ho passato una settimana per
conoscere il sistema delle pari
opportunità in svezia il primo ministero
con cui mi hanno fatto incontrare al
ministero dell'economia e ho chiesto
come mai perché non mi fate incontrare
il ministero delle pari opportunità
il ministro mi ha detto perché noi
passando dal quinto posto al quarto
posto e quindi dando più occupazione le
donne e di conseguenza più asili nido
per permette lavorare miglioriamo il pil
quindi un dato estremamente importante
quello di cui stiamo parlando
una rappresentazione che aiuti le
bambine ma anche i bambini vedremo in
ultima analisi a direbbero l'inglese
essere empowered no ad avere non vedersi
rappresentati sempre solo come oggetti
da ultimo siamo como che è lombardia che
ha in italia ma che in europa per chi di
voi viaggio a che fare con i paesi
europei sappiamo che l'immagine che
abbiamo adatta anche attraverso la
nostra televisione non ha certo aiutato
l'immagine
del nostro paese e ad ottenere la
credibilità che ci meritiamo
c'è poco tempo e vi voglio parlare della
cosa forse più bella che è successa dopo
questo documentario le persone che ci
hanno scritto di più sono state alcune
sole ho viste sono qui sono state le
insegnanti ed insegnanti di tutta italia
riceviamo da quattro anni al nostro
semplicissimo blog il corpo delle donne
punto com e alla nostra pagina facebook
migliaia di richieste da tutta italia e
qui c'è un grido è strano che degli
insegnanti debbano scrivere un blog e
dicono dateci degli strumenti di
educazione ai media
c'è un gap tra noi bravissime noi
incontriamo insegnanti insegnanti che
sono eroi ed eroine ma non sono più
formati da anni quindi dateci degli
strumenti perché di fronte a noi ci sono
i nativi digitali che guardano tante
immagini quindi abbiamo strutturato un
corso da quattro anni si chiama nuovi
occhi per i media strumenti di
educazione all'immagine e ai media per
tutti e tutte
andiamo quindi nelle scuole e da veri
attivisti e non diciamo non guardare la
tv perché in un paese democratico la tv
è un diritto e le persone vogliono ed è
giusto che guardano la tv ma chiediamo
una tv migliore e al contempo al
contempo non consegnamo un'altra
generazione al nulla e quindi diamo
strumenti cosa vuol dire
e avviene lo stesso lo stesso passaggio
che avviene quando impariamo a leggere
attraverso la capacità di leggere le
parole possiamo in un futuro agire la
cittadinanza attiva saremo meno
manipolabili la stessa cosa avviene con
le immagini non dire ai ragazzi non
guardare la tv ma dire guarda la con
occhi e responsabili facciamo un piccolo
esperimento andiamo nelle scuole con
registriamo molto di quello che viene
mandata in onda e diciamo cosa avete
visto ieri a ragazzi transformat che è
una trasmissione che va in onda in
fascia preserale benissimo la guardiamo
insieme poi chiediamo avete notato
qualcosa c'è qualcosa che ti disturba
sapresti dire che la telecamera come
viene usata
no perfetto lo rivediamo con delle
indicazioni
allora presentiamo i concorrenti
francesca chi di questa montatura messa
una valletta a tutti gli effetti basta
non sei più largo barozzi della sua fama
concorrenti di questa sera iniziamo con
alessia ha 18 anni e arriva da putignano
è una studentessa ma è anche una
ritrattista bene clienti
e poi poi abbiamo francesco che ha 27
anni arriva da bologna e mi incuriosisce
questa cosa perché è un barman
piace molto la macchina per cucire eh sì
ma io ho una grande passione per la moda
è iniziato anche a cucire somma autorità
teniamoli vestitini e poi abbiamo la
nostra concorrente e francesca a 19 anni
arriva dalla provincia di caserta in
particolare da santa maria capua vetere
questo giusto giusto perfetto lei è una
studentessa è inoltre fa anche lo stesso
possiamo iniziare allora ma in posizione
allora e so che fa ridere però
immaginatevi in assenza di altri agenti
di socializzazione laddove le famiglie
non riescono più a tenere dove la scuola
non riesce più a tenere queste
trasmissioni vanno in onda da 30 anni è
peggio 5 reti su sei in tutti gli orari
e questo creano dei modelli quindi non
interroghiamoci più da adulti quando poi
leggiamo sui giornali tutto questo molto
di questo parte comunque un mezzo
stupendo che potrebbe fare molto
andiamo in migliaia di scuole in alcune
regioni come la toscana e il trentino
sono partiti dei progetti d
formazione formatori e là dove siamo
stati aiutati finanziariamente e in
toscana sono già i 30mila i ragazzini
che hanno potuto seguire le ragazzine
corsi di educazione all'immagine è
un'emergenza alle scuole lo vogliano
ultimamente abbiamo avuto
l'interessamento del ministero speriamo
di riuscire a fare perché senza soldi
non si può
non si può fare nulla finisco dicendo
con delle notizie positive
la stessa cosa che vi ho raccontato
nella televisione accade nelle
pubblicità quindi l'immaginario intero
dell'italia è caratterizzato da una
profonda oggettivizzazione delle donne
ma in ultima analisi anche degli uomini
gli stessi marchi che qui che in italia
usano dei simboli diciamo sessuali
all'estero usano degli altri simboli c'è
uno yogurt che in italia usa dei simboli
sessuali da 20 anni negli altri paesi
d'europa
usa le capre le mucche prativerdi quindi
perchè da noi no perchè questo crea crea
dei modelli e quindi di conseguenza le
generazioni crescono è un modo di
depotenziare e un modo di non rispettare
il terzo articolo della costituzione che
oltre a dire che siamo tutti uguali
recita che ognuno deve essere messo in
grado di esprimere al meglio il proprio
potenziale di persona e quindi questo
immaginario non ci aiuta questa è la
buona notizia il lavoro che abbiamo
fatto noi e tantissime altre attiviste
negli ultimi anni ha fatto sì che ci
siano migliaia di ragazzine che i media
non raccontano ve lo dico io perché non
ci sono solo le ragazzine che vogliono
fare le veline e comunque di quello
responsabilità della mia generazione
migliaia di ragazzine che io chiamo le
attiviste anonime e di ragazzini un 30
per cento che ci segue maschio che sta
rendendo il paese migliore
chiediamo ai media che lo raccontino
protestano civilmente scrivono dedicano
un'ora tutti i giorni del loro tempo e
sono migliaia a scrivere alla tv alle
agenzie di pubblicità dicendo quella
pubblicità mi offende firmato lorella
zanardo giuseppina rossi mariolina
bianchi lo fanno da anni 70 per cento
delle pubblicità che avete visto sono
state ritirate in questo modo
anche in rai questa notte questa honda
sta arrivando nonostante tutti i
problemi che sappiamo ci sono migliaia
di giovani che i media non raccontano
che stanno cambiando il paese
ecco io vi volevo lasciare con questo
dicendo sosteniamo le sosteniamo perché
il patto generazionale altrimenti
rischia di interrompersi invece è una
spirale che aderito di continuare